- [Instructor] In other
videos we introduce ourselves
to the idea of a density curve,
which is a summary of a distribution,
a distribution of data, and in the future
we'll also look at things
like probability density.
But what I want to talk
about in this video is
think about what we can glean from them,
the properties, how we can
describe density curves
and the distributions they represent.
And we have four of them right over here,
and the first thing I
want to think about is
if we can approximate what value would be
the middle value or the
median for the data set
described by these density curves.
So just to remind ourselves,
if we have a set of numbers
and we order them from least to greatest,
the median would be the middle value,
or the midway between
the middle two values.
In a case like this, we
want to find the value
for which half of the
values are above that value
and half of the values are below.
So in looking at a density curve,
you'd want to look at the area,
and you'd want to say, OK, at what value
do we have equal area
above and below that value?
And so for this one, just eyeballing it,
this value right over
here would be the median.
And in general, if you have a symmetric
distribution like this, the median will be
right along that line of symmetry.
Here we have a slightly
more unusual distribution,
this would be called
a bimodal distribution
where you have two major lumps right
over here, but it is symmetric.
And that point of symmetry
is right over here,
and so this value, once
again, would be the median.
Another way to think about it is,
the area to the left of that value
is equal to the area to the right
of that value, making it the median.
But what if we're dealing with
non-symmetric distributions?
Well we'd want to do the same principle.
We would want to think,
at what value is the area
on the right and the
area on the left equal?
And once again this isn't
going to be super exact,
but I'm going to try to approximate it.
You might be tempted
to go right at the top
of this lump right over here,
but if I were to do that
it's pretty clear, even eyeballing it,
that the right area right over here
is larger than the left area.
So that would not be the median.
If I move the median a
little bit over to the right,
this maybe right around here,
this looks a lot closer.
Once again, I'm approximating it,
but it's reasonable to
say that the area here
looks pretty close to the
area right over there.
And if that is the case,
then this is going to be the median.
Similarly, on this one right over here,
maybe right over here, and once again
I'm just approximating it,
but that seems reasonable,
that this area is equal to that one,
even though this is
longer it's much lower,
this part of the curve is much higher
even though it goes on less to the right.
So that's the median for well behaved
continuous distributions like this,
it's going to be the value
for which the area to the left
and the area to the right are equal.
But what about the mean?
Well the mean is, you take
each of the possible values
and you weight it by their frequencies,
you weight it by their frequencies
and you add all of that up.
And so for symmetric distributions
your mean and your median
are actually going to be the same.
So this is going to be your mean as well,
this is going to be your mean as well.
If you want to think about
it in terms of physics,
the mean would be your balancing point,
the point at which you would want to put
a little fulcrum and you would
want to balance the distribution.
And so you could put a little fulcrum here
and you could imagine that this thing
would balance, this thing would balance.
And that all comes out of this idea of the
weighted average of all
of these possible values.
What about for these less
symmetric distributions?
Well let's think about it over here.
Where would I have to put
the fulcrum, or what does
our intuition say if we
wanted to balance this?
Well, we have equal areas on either side,
but when you have this long tail
to the right it's going to pull the mean
to the right of the median in this case.
And so our balance point is probably
going to be something closer to that.
And once again, this
is me approximating it,
but this would roughly be our mean.
It would sit, in this case,
to the right of our median.
Let me make it clear, this
median is referring to that,
the mean is referring to this.
In this case, because
I have this long tail
to the left, it's likely
that I would have to
balance it out right over here.
So the mean would be this
value, right over there.
And there's actually a term for these
non-symmetric distributions where
the mean is varying from the median.
Distributions like this are
referred to as being skewed.
And this distribution,
where you have the mean
to the right of the median, where you have
this long tail to the right,
this is called right skewed.
Now, the technical idea
of skewness can get
quite complicated, but generally speaking,
you can spot it out when you have
a long tail on one direction,
that's the direction in
which it will be skewed,
or if the mean is to that
direction of the median.
So the mean is to the right of the median,
so generally speaking, that's going
to be a right skewed distribution.
So the opposite of that,
here the mean is to the left
of the median and we have this long tail
on the left of our distribution,
so generally speaking
we will describe these as
left skewed distributions.